how's that bong is loud yeah I agree
as you guys could see or I heard and you
can see the visual window sound sound
like a loved one it sound like a dog
training book sounds like be a lot of
things they've one other thing it could
be beaver
[Music]
hello welcome to my youtube channel my
name is Grace help like if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now what do you think about that yeah
all right many words Chester see so I
never feel comfortable in front of a
camera does the man have a youtube
channel for seven years
oh one that oh god we are going to do a
video that has been requested a lot on
my youtube channel and across a lot of
my social media platform it is called
the drastic challenge yeah we're doing
it and if you haven't seen one of these
videos it's there's a lot on YouTube to
watch how do you feel about doing the
chapstick challenge I feel fantastic
I've never actually watched chubs
chapstick John I don't know exactly
which is interesting that you would do
this video I'm trying to keep up with
things that are current popular
interesting things that really you know
tell traditional media like watch out
okay are you ready to play I I can brush
my teeth
great I'll go first that's chapstick
this one's chapstick this is not
chapstick this is not chapstick it is
chapstick correct jessic sock what is it
chapstick no it's not justice yeah
Tastykake chapstick that is a fixed
device Wow well that was amazing we
nailed that how do you feel yeah very
consistent my own brand thank you guys
so much for watching the chapstick
challenge with Chester see make sure you
go subscribe to this channel if you
haven't already because tomorrow we'll
be posting a new video posted in a year
something like that I don't know that
well I mean haven't done I know what I
want to do on YouTube now
again I'm going back to the roots i I've
got all these songs and ideas have this
YouTube channel and I want to keep that
I'm going back to the Tuesdays Tuesday
videos in digital music on there I'll be
done by the end and when we talking
about stuff that's why it's really good
time see I'll see you over there I don't
know
haha I can feel flavored chapstick where
are you what is this this is a sex toy
you see what you see you see this no you
should leave that in I want you guys to
know the truth about what's happening
behind the scene here just like your
biggest troll video yet
yeah alright that's yeah